you thought we'd reach the final straw
before we have reached it now Nadim
zahawi Chancellor for 24 hours has now
written to the Prime Minister and told
him to go this is the letter the Nadim
zahawi the new chancellor has sent Boris
Johnson he says I've yesterday I made
clear to the Prime Minister alongside my
colleagues in number 10. there was only
one direction this was going and he
should leave with dignity out of respect
and in hopes he would listen to an old
friend of 30 years they've known each
other a very long time I kept this
Council private although we did bring
you news of it yesterday he said I'm
heartbroken he hasn't listened he's now
undermining the incredible achievements
of this government this late hour and
then he says the country deserves a
government that's not only stable but
which acts with Integrity prime minister
he says you know in your heart what the
right thing to do is go now so the new
Chancellor says that he took the job
because someone needs to step in and he
thinks that he knows that people think
badly of him for doing it but he says he
defends stepping in but he's now saying
the Prime Minister needs to go for the
good of the party and the country so
that is pretty Stark and I can't imagine
okay it will be long before we see a
lectern and this all starts to come to
an end okay my head's spinning now so he
was education secretary then he became
Chancellor then he went to see the Prime
Minister yesterday to say that's enough
and now he's saying no telling us that
he said that's enough and he's saying to
the Prime Minister publicly go now this
Nadeem zahawi when Rishi sunak resigned
on Tuesday nights kicking all this off
it was thought Nadim zahari might resign
as well he took the job as Chancellor he
said you know he sits sat there in the
studio with you saying yes I believe the
Prime Minister has Integrity we've got a
new exciting agenda about tax cuts and
yet 24 hours later he's saying actually
I've been making clear to him already
that he needs to go and this country
needs a government which acts with
Integrity it's suggesting that that is
not currently happening so it's a Game
of Thrones isn't it okay I mean but
those that were criticizing Nadeem
zahawi for what he did to look at the
other side of the coin he could say that
he was acting with Integrity because
somebody has to do the job of Chancellor
somebody has to run the government
say that when he took the job if that
was the reason there are all sorts of
rumors that he threatened to resign if
they didn't give him the job of
Chancellor denied by Nadim zahawi's team
and him and him um but still persistent
reports today suggestions that he's been
planning a leadership campaign for a
little while and may throw his hat into
the ring but he is now saying he's told
the Prime Minister privately and is now
telling him publicly to go okay wow
that's a prediction in a day of big
developments that is the biggest